[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
I believe that the fast is the most
effective way to grow your business is
to model the strategies that people
who've already done what you're trying
to do so today we're gonna look at how a
young man who grew up during World War
two
didn't have much in terms of money and
didn't come from a wealthy background
went on to become a legend in the
fashion industry this is a story of
Giorgio Armani and the top three lessons
you can learn from his success Giorgio
Armani grew up in a small northern
Italian town of Gaucho Enza our money
grew up in a family of five that was
hard working but never had too much
money to go around his childhood was not
an easy one the realities of the second
world war in which Italy was caught at
the time were all too apparent to the
young Armani after losing two young
friends to a war bomb Armani and his
sister also became a target of
machine-gun fire from an overhead plane
however Armani and his family survived
the war and relocated to Milan it was a
city decidedly marked by class division
and one in which our mannie's parents
struggled to rebuild their lives they
found that hard to find their footing in
as much bigger and tougher City than
their little town of catch Enza and so
he enrolled in a medical school at the
University of Bologna where he studied
for two years to become a doctor however
when he discovered the sight of blood
made him weak Armani knew that line of
work was not for him in 1953 Armani was
called to fulfill his military
obligations which he accepted eagerly as
a chance to clear his head and gain new
direction in his life for all of his
experience Imani was assigned to the
infirmary however he quickly grew bored
with his prospects and realized that war
life was not the romantic notion he had
seen in the movies he took a short break
from the service and took a trip to
Milan that would forever change his life
that was where he met a friend of his
who happen to work at Milan's largest
department store and who would give him
his first break into the fashion
industry after the meeting Armani said
that he had become believer in destiny
that destiny has made him known for his
costly tailored sleep power suits and
clean high-quality fabrics that everyone
from the who's who of Hollywood to the
bankers on Wall Street have fallen in
love with now Jorge Armani's company has
over 1.5 billion dollars in revenue and
a retail empire that
to more than 35 countries by following
his passion and by having the courage to
switch careers Giorgio Armani was able
to go from almost poverty to building
one of the most successful businesses in
the fashion industry to help you explode
your business here are three action
items that you can learn from Giorgio
Armani action them number one stick to
your vision as an entrepreneur it's
important to have a vision that guides
your business decisions what bigger game
are you playing
what kind of mark you want to leave on
your industry what do you stand for as a
person answering these questions and
keeping your vision top of mind will
help make the difficult decisions easier
while you're in the day-to-day of
running your business for over 30 years
Armani has made a name for himself as a
designer whose clothing was elegant yet
subtle from day one he has stood out
from his competitors including the likes
of Gianni Versace who chose instead to
emphasize the sexuality of clothes over
those subtlety and has increased the
risk a nature whose designs each year
Hermione's approach to the fashion was a
pragmatic one his vision was to create
clothing that was both classic that
would send a test of time and that was
meticulously designed that was a vision
he stayed true to throughout his entire
career unlike many of his competitors
Armani believed that fashion should
evolve over time rather than change
drastically each and every year
according to our money remained true to
yourself in your philosophy
I designed for real people I think of
our customers all the time there is no
virtue whatsoever in creating clothing
or accessories that are not practical
you have to think of the future if not
we would close down I find a gratifying
that I've launched a lasting style but
of course I feel the need to reach
forward to questioner myself to take
risks I always want to refresh and renew
action limb number two stretch your
brand the easiest way to grow business
is to sell more products and services to
existing clients provided that it fits
your long-term vision and it adds more
value to your customers look for ways to
expand your business by adding new
offerings if your clients are happy with
what they've already bought from you
then they'll line up to keep working
with you
you're not just growing a business
you're finding new ways to help
customers solve problems there was never
any doubts when it came to our monies
talents of the designer however when his
partner in both life and business passed
away our money was left to defend his
talent as a businessman he had little to
no business experience but didn't want
to give up on his dream of expanding his
company to this end their money decided
to create new product lines including
many less exclusive and less expensive
spin-offs of his luxury label he
introduced Armani Jeans for casual
clothes and Armani Exchange which
consists of trending urban clothing
while he's primarily still known the
world over for his fashion designs a
mining has moved on from clothing to
launch product lines and include
accessories home furnishings restaurants
car interiors chocolates and most
recently hotels
according to Armani when I began making
jeans the press was skeptical that
someone who made luxury ready-to-wear
could start something so commercial but
I considered it a medium to speak with a
less affluent clientele
I have always paid great attention to
having brands that don't overlap I
choose a brand for a particular market
and balance my collections in terms of
look price distribution and location
when supply of fashion items become so
enormous the consumer tends to choose
the leading brand which means that
others are left behind and to establish
real credibility is no simple matter
actually um number three follow your
conscience as you grow your business
your values will be tested numerous
times do you say yes to a deal that
might make you a lot of money but isn't
in line with what you believe in when
things aren't black and white how far
are you willing to walk down the gray
line let your conscience be your guide
new opportunities will continue coming
to you you don't need to compromise who
you are to be a successful entrepreneur
our money believes at the heart of all
successful businesses are successful
relationships thus establishing positive
interactions between his company and its
communities and consumers is a
in step towards generating healthy
business growth to this end our money
has committed his company to what he
believes are positive social ideals our
money is at the forefront of companies
demonstrating the potential to be a
force for change he's refusing operating
the bubble design and luxury clothes for
consumers irrespective of the world in
which they all live much like he stood
up in the face of critics who thought he
would never make it as a businessman so
towards armani now standing up for the
social issues he believes in and proving
that any company can do the same
according to armani it is a fact that in
the West we live in a capitalist society
but that doesn't mean that we cannot be
guided by the idea of a social
conscience in our work yes fashion
design requires consumers to consume but
we can do our bit for society by running
our companies in a socially responsible
way and by creating products that
promote respect for social and
environmental issues the best way to
make a contribution fashion is to
promote the idea that a fundamental
interest in preserving the environment
is itself fashionable
so remember stick to your vision stretch
your brand and follow your conscience to
finish up this video I wanted to share
one of my favorite true stories about
George Armani and some of his most
inspirational quotes our money has
designed clothing for some of the most
influential people on the planet but
according to Monty himself some of his
proudest designs were for Princess
Charlene of Monaco
he's been clothing her since she first
wore one of his pieces in 2008 at the
Olympic Games in Beijing he spoke to
Vogue magazine about designing her
wedding gown and believes Princess
Charlene knows how to wear my creations
with nonchalance and confidence of youth
getting to the point where a royalty
requests a specific designers clothing
is considered the pinnacle of a
designer's career where our money
continues to challenge the market and
reinvent his designs which was shown in
his design for Princess Charlene's
wedding dress
according to Armani I felt the new
design was appropriate given that there
would inevitably be comparisons with
Princess Grace and those such
comparisons are of course a sign of
admiration each person has their own
individual and unique style and styles
and expression of the times he goes on
the save it was one of his greatest
creations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining me for another
edition modeling the masters if you
liked the video you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes me want to do more of these videos
for you guys I'd also love to hear what
you have to think if you want to leave a
comment under the video so thank you and
you'll see you on the next episode
[Music]
you
[Music]